[Musique]
bienvenue dans pôle it mag l'émission
politique d'ayrté france comme tous les
week-ends on débat avec nos
contributeurs des grands sujets de
l'actualité politique de la semaine
aujourd'hui nous sommes avec lydia
guirous ce essayiste et membre du bureau
politique les républicains fassent
allemand de jean pollution président
honoraire du conseil régional d'île de
france
invité sur ce plateau également joseph
thouvenel vice président de la cftc et
jean claude mailly ancien secrétaire
général de force ouvrière merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur rt france
et c'est à la une cette semaine regarder
après 45 jours d'une mobilisation
historique le torchon brûle entre
syndicats réformistes contestataires et
leurs bases des individus ont fait
irruption vendredi au siège de la cfdt
pour protester contre la stratégie du
syndicat réformiste laurent bergé s'est
félicité du retrait de l'âge pivot du
projet de loi sur la réforme des
retraites un climat social qui se tend
alors que la mobilisation faiblit mais
une contestation toujours soutenu par
une majorité de français alors que le
premier miss me aveline tourner la page
du dossier cette semaine écoutez ya
jamais eu autant de
le citoyen français dans leur diversité
d'ailleurs ils restent favorables et
soutiennent ce mouvement qui trouvent
que cette réforme est injuste qu'elle
est incompréhensible
ça devrait interroger plus tôt le
gouvernement et une majorité de
l'opinion qui supporte notre point de
vue sur sur cette réforme et son
caractère dangereux et pour le coup je
veux dire que dans le privé
l'opinion elle est majoritaire elle est
majoritairement contre ce projet
certains de ceux qui sont inquiets ou
qui s'opposent à ce projet ont choisi de
manifester ou de faire grève
je voudrais dire un mot sur le sujet en
indiquant comme j'ai déjà eu l'occasion
de le dire que la grève à la ratp et la
grève à la sncf me paraissait sans issue
et qu'elle n'avait que trop duré mais
jean claude mailly vous avez été
secrétaire général de force ouvrière de
2004 à 2018
vous allez connu trois présidents
successifs
nicolas sarkozy françois hollande et
emmanuel macron à prendre pendant la
première année vous avez été en première
ligne contre la loi travail contre la
réforme des retraites en 2010 sous
nicolas sarkozy est ce que vous sentez
avec emmanuel macron un changement de
méthode dans le
dialogue et les négociations qui peut y
avoir entre les syndicats et l'exécutif
oui je crois pour pour deux raisons la
première c'est que emmanuel macron
candidat à la présidence avait déjà
commencé a expliqué que pour lui la
place des syndicats
c'est essentiellement dans l'entreprise
ou dans l'administration mais pas dans
les débats nationaux d'une certaine
manière il considère lui que tout ce qui
est national relève de l'intérêt général
et l'euro l'intérêt général c'est l'état
et le gouvernement
donc il y avait déjà ce problème qui
perdure d'une manière d'une manière ou
d'une autre et la deuxième raison moi
j'ai vu trois temps depuis qu'il a été
élu président et public je parle sur le
dialogue social
il y avait un premier temps c'était
celui des ordonnances travail où nous
avons demandé nous mais d'autres sort à
peu près tous les syndicats d'ailleurs
ont demandé est-ce qu' une véritable
concertation que ça ne passe pas comme
il souhaitait le faire au départ pendant
l'été la concertation a eu lieu à
l'époque elle a eu lieu on a obtenu des
choses et beaucoup de choses qu'on n'a
pas obtenu aussi il ya des choses que
qui sont toujours pas bonnes dans ses
ordonnances le dialogue
je pense qu'il ya une deuxième étape ça
a été la réforme de la sncf où là il est
passé en force d'une certaine manière il
ya eu des grèves etc
mais il est passé en force et je pense
qu'ils se sont dit maintenant bastan
peut tout faire et que le dialogue à
partir d'un on a pris un coup et on l'a
vu sur d'autres dossiers comme
l'assurance chômage où ils sont passés
en force et selon moi aussi aujourd'hui
sur le dossier retraites
vous êtes d'accord avec ça joseph
thouvenel est ce que le dialogue s'est
quelque peu ternie avec l'exécutif
on le voit dans dans cette réforme des
retraites un beau coup de deux
des concertations d'ailleurs qui ne sont
même pas qualifiés de concertation par
les syndicats qu'il sait faire que sur
la retraite je suis d'accord avec
l'analyse de jean claude après en avoir
des points de divergence entente de tous
mais là franchement on a connu une
période où on a on a voulu nous faire
croire une concertation
on a passé plus de 18 mois en discussion
mais la concertation où la négociation
c'est un échange en vérité il n'y a pas
eu d'échangés en vérité eu des 2000
vérité
les demi vérités se dire qu'il ya des
2000 mensonges et où le pouvoir a fait
et dit ce qu'ils voulaient dire votre
première question c'est sur le projet du
gouvernement avec une majorité de
français contre le projet mais ils ont
bien de la chance c'est connaissent le
projet un projet un projet est dans le
flou jusqu'à la dernière minute ça fait
partie de la stratégie pour passer cette
réforme
alors écoutez soit ils sont carrément
nul de très mauvais stratège parce que
très franchement vous prenez un exemple
les avocats voilà des gens qui me disent
nous on n'a de réserve sa marge en les
comptant
pourquoi elle se fâcher avec les avocats
qu'est-ce qu'il suffit de leur dire les
amis vous voulez votre système
très bien alors à froid on passe un
accord vous le gérer mais le jour où si
rapide parce que peut-être que dans dix
quinze ans vous n'aurez plus de réserve
parce que pourquoi ils sont
bénéficiaires les avocats ce parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de jeunes avocats et
beaucoup moins de retraités
mais dans ces cas là on leur laisse un
espace de liberté par exemple
aujourd'hui à froid ont signé un accord
si un jour venir au secours pour notre
système parce que leurs déficits
voilà dans quelles conditions l'état
interviendra et on a oublié là puisqu'il
s'agissait pas de stratégie sur la
question n'importe quel stratège c'est
que si on veut avancer on n'ouvre pas
tous les fronts à la fois et on ne voit
pas tous les fronts à la fois c'est ce
qu'a fait ce gouvernement ne pas donner
de chiffrage notamment a été aussi très
critiqué par par les syndicats jean paul
huchon vous aussi vous allez
périence de de la longévité en tout cas
en tant qu'homme politique
comment est-ce que vous analysez 7 ce
bras de fer entre l'exécutif et les
syndicats est ce que emmanuel macron
clairement à cette volonté de deux cas
c'est de casser et de faire taire en
tout cas certains syndicats pas
forcément les réformistes alors jean
claude mailly a dit tout à l'heure la
pensée profonde des mails mâcon c'est
que tout ce qui relève de l'entreprise
doit être gardé dans un coin et tout ce
qui relève du débat national ou de
l'intérêt d'ailleurs nationale c'est
l'état qui l'incarné donc c'est le
président de la république puisqu'il
pense lui incarner totalement l'état il
l'a fait non seulement avec les
syndicats mais il a fait aussi avec ces
collectivités locales avec tous les
corps intermédiaires
donc ça c'est sa pensée profonde et je
le vis les gilets jaunes auraient dû
contribuer à faire évoluer son point de
vue il a fait des débats il a rencontré
quand même pas mal de gens mais non on
continue et je pense qu'il est persuadé
qu' ils portent l'intérêt du pays par
conséquent les syndicats sont plutôt des
les frères des emmerdeurs des empêcheurs
de tous deux ne j'irai en rond alors moi
qui ai bossé avec un type d michel
rocard qui avait vraiment le sens de la
négociation de la concertation avec les
syndicats
tout ça me choque énormément et je
considère que c'est d'une inefficacité
puisqu'aujourd'hui plus ça va plus on a
l'impression que les gens sont
mécontents
alors bien sûr qu'il ya eu des
amodiations que edouard philippe a fait
un effort bien sûr mais la question fait
qu' on ne sort pas de cette affaire et
tout le monde est aussi énervé qu'avant
avec y compris des risques des actions
personnelles ses terres ce n'est plus
seulement une affaire gouvernement
edouard philippe
c'est une affaire entre les français
macron alors gens qu'on écoute
emmanuel macron
ce qu'il avait déclaré en mars 2010 est
justement sur sa définition des
syndicats on vient d'en parler donc
regarder on est dans un drôle de système
de même où chaque jour dans le pays
on dit qu intermédiaire démocratie
territoriale démocratie sociale
laissez-nous faire et quand on donne la
main des bonbons monsieur c'est dur
reprenez la alors ça c'était le 21
février 2019
emmanuel macron qui recevait les
présidents des départements agacé
justement parce que les syndicats
réclament des concertations et quand on
leur donne la main il la redonne en
quelque sorte un savez ça effet pense
que c'est totalement inexact
puisqu'on parle des retraites quel est
le système qui fonctionne bien qui est
quasiment à l'équilibré avec des
milliards de réserves
c'est le système géré paritairement par
les partenaires sociaux
on peut dire qu'il est imparfait mais
que le chef de l'état nous dise pas
quand on fonctionne on n'est pas capable
de fonctionner réaction jean claude
mailly à cette déclaration
ça c'était au moment des discussions sur
l'assurance chômage c'est une
déclaration en fait c'est un leurre 1
parce que l'état a mis 10 vous négociez
mais voilà ce que vous devez obtenir à
la fin donc la négociation savez tout le
monde savait qu'elle était quasiment
impossible qu'on craintes après c'est
facile de dire ben oui mais ils savent
pas négocier donc j'ai obligé de
retrouver là on est dans cette même
logique d'une certaine d'une certaine
manière c'est pas le cadrage et elle par
l'état que y'a plus la liberté de
négociation c'est évident on savait très
bien à l'époque à moi j'étais pas
négociateur mais joseph suivait sans
savez très bien à l'époque le patronat
n'accepteraient pas certaines choses
donc la négociation n'était pas possible
et sur les retraites c'est un peu ça
quand même la situation aujourd'hui donc
quand vous cadrez tellement l'année que
je vous rappelle qu'il voulait même
étatisée l'assurance chômage
d'une certaine manière il a réussi dont
hélas quand vous regardez moi j'ai lu
attentivement par exemple le projet de
loi sur les retraites projet de loi sur
les retraites à la fin c'est une
étatisation complète du système qu'on
nous parle pas de paritarisme
vous allez avoir autour de la table
l'état les employeurs publics les
employeurs privés les professions
libérales qui va diriger de bidules
salak l'état c'est obligatoirement
l'état qui va diriger y compris joseph
évoqué le cas des avocats mais par
exemple sur les réserves
rien n'est clair on va dire ben on
pouvait garder une caisse autonome mais
dans le cadre du système universel et
les réserves ont beau vous allez une
progressivement les utiliser pour payer
les droits passé donc on est on est sur
un système
moi j'ai toujours pensé que le
néolibéralisme conduisait parfois
d'autoritarisme social mais je crois que
c'est l'expression la plus forte là on
est avec un autoris autoritarisme
sociale qui se traduit pas une
étatisation complète du système et la
fin d'un mode de gestion des joseph à
raison qui fonctionnait très bien sur
les retraites complémentaires ou depuis
la fin de la guerre un système qui
fonctionnait bien sûr bien sûr avec 70
milliards à peu près de réserve
aujourd'hui les gens qui ne sont pas
obligatoirement mécontents de la façon
dont les choses se passent et c'est donc
on change de nature complètement lydia
guirous ce que pensez vous de ce bras de
fer entre l'exécutif et les syndicats
c'est vrai que certains français en tout
cas disait cette france n'est pas
réformable au moins emmanuel macron à a
dit qu'il allait faire des réformes il
s'y tient quel est votre votre sentiment
là-dessus emmanuel macron si tiens oui
ils avaient toute façon il n'a pas le
choix en réalité il doit il doit
réformer il doit démontrer qu'il est
déterminé il doit démontrer qu'il ne
bougera pas qu'il ne cèdera pas parce
qu'il a été élu sur cette promesse là
parce qu'il a été sur sept élus sur
cette promesse là et puis sur cette
posture aussi c'est l'homme qui va faire
entrer la france dans le nouveau monde
sauf que le nouveau monde pour le moment
moi ce que j'en observe c'est plus de
violence plus de blocage une grève d'une
longueur comme je n'en n'ai jamais connu
avec mon peu d'expérience mais voilà
tout de même la hausse un peu de
jeunesse ans voilà une france qui est
bloquée qui va vers plus de violence
donc ce que ce que je vois c'est qu'il
doit y avoir quelque part quand même une
forme de mépris des partenaires sociaux
et que la méthode n'est pas la bonne 18
mois dix-huit mois de concertation parce
que c'est réellement 18 mois de
concertation où c'est de la réunionite
pour occuper et pour dire je vous reçois
je reçois les partenaires sociaux est en
réalité tout est déjà ficelé et il n'y a
pas de marge de négociation je crois
qu'il ya un problème de méthode et je
n'ai pas l'impression que ce qu'il
propose que ce soit dans le fond et même
en termes de communication est de nature
à rassurer les français
et là il ya un vrai problème parce que
ça apporte de l' angoisse et beaucoup
beaucoup d'inquiétude
c'est je me demande si c'est pas
finalement une fidélité au en même temps
de l'ambiguïté on sait pas très bien où
on va et en réalité ça crispe et sacré
sacré de l'incompréhension et donc de la
violence beaucoup de réactions des
syndicats j'en cite quelques unes les 18
mois de concertation c'étaient pour
changer des virgules et des points ainsi
parle fabrice michaud le secrétaire
général de la cgt
cette concertation n'a été que du cinéma
finalement le texte initial est
quasiment le même à l'arrivée septembre
jusqu'au jusqu'au boutisme finalement
dans la négociation jean paul huchon
sacrés de la contestation est sacré de
la violence sociale
oui et je suis même inquiet on ma part
je trouve que on a rarement vu une telle
un tel refus une telle opposition entre
le gouvernement et les oreilles sont
syndicale
au début on a voulu mettre de côté en
dix ans les syndicats nous empêche de
travailler s'étira et après l'hégire
région il a bien fallu un peu rétablir
un contact mais ça continue et je suis
inquiet parce que je vois les formes
d'intervention dans la bataille sociale
sont de plus en plus incontrôlable
cerveau ce qui fait passer l'autre jour
aussi oui et puis au théâtre et ses
atouts sa montre une espèce de ciblage
presque personnalisé et au fond c'est
pas les rapports qu'une démocratie
sociale moderne peut avoir avec elle
même vous dire que si ça ne se passe pas
du tout comme ça ni en allemagne ni même
en grande bretagne qui est pourtant un
pays beaucoup plus libérale
il ya quelque chose d'inquiétant et qui
je pense doit également inquiéter nos
partenaires européens parce qu'ils se
disent au fond
bien sûr il a fait des réformes et que
jamais à quoi ça mène finalement et et
la france est devenue un pays entre
guillemets dangereux et violents voilà
voilà la question
un dernier rapport sur la délinquance
qui est assez accablant ces derniers
jours joseph thouvenel est ce que m dos
à dos les syndicats c'est ce que cherche
emmanuel macron aujourd'hui je sais pas
mais la terre ce qui s'est passé elle
était notamment
d'abord c'est pas les syndicats qui ont
attaqué d'assez de l'été on est en
désaccord avec la cfdt mais on a une
montée de la violence et de
l'intolérance
on voit des violences policières et elle
alors que je défendrai je continuerai à
défendre la police qu'un rôle essentiel
et très difficile mais en même temps si
à cette montée de la violence ce qui
aussi
un certain laisser faire de ce côté là
on a un vrai un vrai problème de
fonctionnement se l'était dit de notre
démocratie donc de montée de la violence
à peu partout mais la méthode en
elle-même est une méthode très violente
ne pas écouter ne pas avancer ensemble
quand je disais demi vérités égal 2 mai
avec 2000 mensonge mais enfin quand on
nous dit la france n'est pas réformable
donc moi il faut que j'y aille mais
c'est totalement faux est ce que notre
pays est celui des années 60 70 80 non
est-ce que les retraites n'ont pas
évolué j'ai un salarié du privé
mais avant de calculer sur les 10
meilleures années aujourd'hui c'est sur
les 25 avant de demander de travailler
beaucoup moins longtemps dans la durée
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus avant
calcul est ma retraite sur l'évolution
des salaires
aujourd'hui c'est sur un indice des prix
se sont pas des réformes importantes
elles n'ont pas été faites
donc si le politique croit vraiment ce
qu'il dit que la france est irréformable
c'est qu'il sait pas comment fonctionne
d'où les erreurs et doucet accentuation
de conflit qu'ils sont nous on est dans
une organisation et cftc où on pense que
la fin est dans les moyens comme l'arbre
et dans la semence dire que quand on se
fixe un objectif la façon d'arriver à
cet objectif construire lui-même
l'objectif là la méthode est exécrable
et on le voit très bien on est en train
d'opposer les parties du pays contre
d'autres parties du pays
c'est exactement ce qu'il faut pas faire
il ya aussi la base notamment des
syndicats réformistes c'est peut-être ce
qui a provoqué aussi cette intrusion au
siège de la cfdt une déconnexion jean
claude mailly que vous sentez vous entre
la base de
et certains de réunir 5000 noms je pense
pas que ce soit plus qu'avant ça mais
vous savez il y avait un nouveau
phénomène par rapport est à 15 ou 20 ans
il ya 15 ou 1 tente sur des dossiers
comme ça c'est ce que j'appelle des
mobilisations entre guillemets verticale
vers les confédérations appelé les
salariés du public du privé ça existe
encore on le voit aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui avec les réseaux sociaux
vous avez des mobilisations de caractère
horizontal 1 et ça quelles que soient
les réseaux et ça ça change beaucoup de
choses ce qui s'est passé au théâtre si
elles peuvent les réseaux sociaux
seraient pas été possible par exemple je
pensais exemple un bon donc après il
peut y avoir
j'ai condamné l'intrusion aussi à jouer
à cet été mais c'est pas la première
fois qu'on a ce type de phénomène y en a
eu c'est faux il y en a eu à la cgt on
agresse fdt etc ou localement ou
nationalement un mais mais en tous les
cas ce qui est clair c'est qu'en termes
de méthode
moi je dis savent pas faire faut bien
comprendre si on a le sentiment que sur
un dossier comme celui des retraites
ils sont partis d'un slogan qu'un beau
slogan entre nous un euro cotisé dans
les mêmes droits qui peut être contre sa
personne
et en effet ça n'est qu'un slogan
c'est comme si vous construisez une
maison et puis vous commencez à mettre
les murs et puis vous faites pas la
coordination des corps de métiers vous
avez oublié les fondations et ben voilà
on est dans cette situation aujourd'hui
toutes les phénomènes de transition tout
ce qui réserve tout ça rien n'a été
examinée
donc c'est passé un certain amateurisme
assez dénoncé aussi par certains leaders
oui je pense qu'il ya une forme d'une
forme d'amateurisme soyeux ag prenait
fin entre nous il ya combien de
ministres politiques au gouvernement n'a
pas beaucoup alors réagit pas que tous
les mises au vert politique au sens
profond du thème bien un peu d'ailleurs
rien de tout ça joue ça arrive dans call
of social ministres politiques gentil
mais c'est ça aussi c'est un choix enfin
et même l macron il gouverne seul
les ministres sont des espèces de
carpettes
les parlementaires doivent aussi être
des carpettes et ça n'est pas du tout
comme ça que doit fonctionner une
démocratie et il a choisi ses ministres
clairement c'est une fausse bonne idée
on va mettre des techniciens ils vont
nous faire ça à la pépère tranquille
non c'est pas du tout comme ça et
l'incapacité de certains misent pourtant
charge de choses très importantes comme
gagner du temps aux bains le résultat il
a aujourd'hui un et il n'y a pas de
ministres politiques y en a pas il y en
a eu un
avec nicolas hulot peut-être dans une
certaine mesure mais y'en a pas et si
vous ne pouvez pas gouverner enfin c'est
une illusion extraordinaire et terrible
d'imaginer qu'on peut gouverner un pays
comme la france le nôtre tout seul sans
se préoccuper ni des corps
intermédiaires ni même des
parlementaires
cc c'est quand même une fif thème qui
moi m'échappe totalement n'importe qui
ayant fait un peu d'administration c'est
que ça fonctionne pas comme ça tu
hermach est quand même fait le mot
respect des décors intermédiaire a été
évoquée ce mot respect ce que vous êtes
stouvenel vous sentez qu'il ya moins de
respect vous savez la bonne dénonciation
macérer gilet jaune
j'ai jaune comme beaucoup départ je me
suis dit tiens c'est l'échelle mais
syndicat thomas nous l'a dit mais je me
suis mais non il n'y a pas de gilet
jaune dans les entreprises pourquoi
parce que là où le corps intermédiaires
que nous formons syndicats de salariés
syndicats patronaux notre intelligence
collective fait qu'au quotidien
on appréhende les problèmes et on les
résout et l'art c'est l'espace sono
laisse encore notre liberté
la gestion des retraites du privé c'est
notre espace de liberté et on est bon il
ya d'autres exemples comme ça donc quand
le corps intermédiaires on lui laisse
son espace de liberté et fonctionne bien
problème c'est qu'on le tue on le voit
sur le logement par exemple aujourd'hui
le logement qu'était le 1% logement a
été en fait nationalisé l'état décide de
tout terminer ça va coûter plus cher ça
va être moins efficace mais parce que
franchement après tout comme toute femme
politique agit aussi avec son caractère
bien je peux vous promettre une chose
c'est que j'ai des défauts mais jamais
je m'appellerai jupiter et quand je
m'auto proclame jupiter on voit ce que
ça peut entraîner derrière
lui aussi une tentative de politiser en
tout cas l'aide demandée au gilet jaune
de trouver des représentants est ce que
c'était une façon peut-être aussi de
court circuiter les syndicats italiens
ce jeu je pense parce que quand le gilet
jaune sont sont apparus on nous a dit
les syndicats finalement sont des has
been on les met de côté maintenant on va
discuter directement avec l'europe le
peuple et six sociétés et le peuple dans
complètement les gilet jaune et on a vu
qu'à chaque fois qu'un leader des gilet
jaune émerger immédiatement été remis en
question par par les autres voire
parfois la jebba endosser ce rôle en
tout cas voilà et les autres ne lui
reconnaissait pas cette cette légitimité
donc il ya eu du mépris pour pour les
corps intermédiaires pour les syndicats
et aujourd'hui on découvre qu'ils sont
on a découvert qu'il était utile lorsque
la situation a échappé au gouvernement
et au président de la république et j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya une relation qui
est utilitaire
lorsqu'on en a besoin on les reçoit et
on a des relations avec et puis lorsque
c'est plus compliqué on les méprise et
je crois que ce n'est pas une bonne
façon de créer un dialogue social et de
faire avancer une récente et l'autre
écueil à mon sens du gouvernement sur la
sur la réforme des retraites c'est de
s'être attaqué à tous c'est à dire l'âge
donc je laisse à mon âge pivot le les
régimes spéciaux et l'alignement du
public et du privé je crois qui aurait
fallu prendre les dossiers un par un ca
aurai crisper un petit peu moins il
aurait commencé par la fin des régimes
spéciaux peut-être qu'il y aurait eu
moins de manifestations - de soutien de
la part des français et est moins deux
mois de blocage
jean claude mailly là le calendrier est
très serré 1 22 janvier présentation
extrait ça aussi ça empêche tout
dialogue ou non seulement oui moi je
pense que l la sage moi je vais pas tant
de précipitation parce qu'il se vit sont
ils sont pressés précédent sortir il
faut en double il faut une erreur
d'ailleurs parce qu'ils n'en sortiront
pas même si le projet de loi est voté
avec la majorité qu'ils ont eue devant
l'être d'une manière ou d'une autre
rien n'est réglé parce que sa voiture
ait des mois derrière des ordonnances il
ya des décrets faut régler le problème
du financement faut régler le problème
des réserves pour régler le problème dès
qu est ce qu un régime semi autonome
autonome et que c'est tout ça donc ça va
durer des mois
en 2010 quand nicolas sarkozy et son
gouvernement reculer l'âge de deux ans
les syndicats sont descendus dans la rue
on n'a pas gagné c'est passé à condé
passer à autre chose
là on passera pas autre chose ou bien
comprendre que ça va durer durer écoutez
un exemple mais bien sûr mais je vais
prendre un exemple parmi d'autres quand
on lit bien le projet de loi on se rend
compte par exemple qu'il va y avoir une
caisse nationale d'assurance vieillesse
de régime universel je vais commencer n
ai reçu plus quoi moi qui va être un des
établissements publics
les caisses régionales de sécurité
sociale qui gère la retraite dans les
régions qui s'appelle les carsat
disparaissent en tant qu organisme de
sécurité sociale vont devenir des afin
dix sept caisses nationales
vous avez comme des réactions et pareil
dans les institutions de prévoyance et
les institutions de retraite
complémentaire
vous avez les cadres et agents de
direction est à la fois de la sécurité
sociale et de ses institutions qui s'y
attendait ça veut dire qu'on change
complètement le système on tue on tue le
système tel qu'il existait tout ça c'est
un venir oui ça fait partie des débats à
venir donc non je crois qu'ils ont il
aurait dû partir du réel
si on partait d'une feuille blanche sion
dans un pays a aucun système de retraite
on peut très bien confère une
construction qui est peut-être une belle
construction intellectuelle mais bon
essayer de la mettre on ne compare pas
d'une feuille blanche on parle de régime
qui existe dans ses grandes lignes et on
voit les difficultés la complexité mais
franchement je crains même y compris
pour des raisons techniques ce que
j'appelle un accident industriel qu'un
jour on puisse pas payer les retraites
parce que les systèmes informatiques ne
marchons pas quand il a fallu le régime
social des indépendants contourne et
quelques années on l'a basculé au régime
général pas ça a été un sou pas possible
parce que pour des raisons uniquement
technique car vous vous rendez compte
placer beaucoup plus gros c'est puissant
se dissout puis son sens donc il ya un
côté irresponsable
on reste avec nous on continue ce débat
sur la bataille entre les syndicats et
le gouvernement sur la réforme des
retraites l'exécutif at-il guen
ou perdus ce bras de fer les syndicats
en sorte qu'il affaiblit ou fragilisées
aux yeux de l'opinion
on en parle dans quelques minutes à tout
de suite
[Musique]
arrimé des pays africains à l'euro c'est
une évidence bêtise la france a intérêt
à maintenir de français parce que c'est
l'un de ces rares instruments qu'ils ont
de protection de ses intérêts
économiques en afrique
l'écho c'est quelque chose qui a été
fait entre pays africains et sur lequel
la france et l'europe avait pas grand
chose à dire en question rôle ingrat
parité fixe avec une eau mais c'est est
ce que c'est la même monnaie le sujet
aujourd'hui en afrique c'est pas d'avoir
une inflation à 2%
ces espèces de critères qu'on impose
alors c'est des critères de tirer entre
guillemets d'économies matures à des
économies qui sont en développement
studio
[Musique]
dans ce livre on vous découvre
extrêmement proche de votre mari un
couple très fusionnelle à ce que vous
viviez un peu dans la peur avec tino
quai des menaces oui d intimidation
comme brûler les locaux oui mais un
assassinat vraiment jeune ans je pense
que il y croyait pas ceux qui ont été
assassinés étaient les politiques de
journal il était l'âme de ce journal et
oui ils ont tué charlie je voulais pas
que tignes où ce soit une victime
je voulais pas que son nom soit associé
à 8 e-news la victime de charlie je
voulais que l'on se dise à tignes où le
grand dessinateur c'est ça qui est bien
avec un artiste c'est qu'un artiste tant
qu'on publie son travail l'artiste est
vivant
[Musique]
pôle it mag la suite avec nos
contributeurs lydia guirous ce jean paul
huchon joseph thouvenel vice président
de la cftc jean claude mailly ancien
secrétaire général de force ouvrière
on continue de décrypter ce bras de fer
entre l'exécutif et les syndicats
concernant cette réforme des retraites
joseph thouvenel ce fameux âge pivot
compromis soit disant lâché par le
gouvernement dont s'est félicité
d'ailleurs laurent berger est ce que
c'est vraiment une victoire et est ce
que de toute façon il fallait lâcher et
ça c'est déjà prévu dans le texte je
dirais non c'est pas une victoire mais
enfin franchement le président de la
république ne pas nous dire en même
temps j'ai fait une promesse électorale
je vais revoir les retraites et donc je
tiens mes promesses
il a fait aussi la promesse électorale
écrite noir sur blanc
en tout cas c'est ce que j'ai reçus à la
maison 1 où je ne toucherait pas à l'âge
de 62 ans exactement comment en même
temps après 1h pivot ce corner oui c'est
mais c'est toujours 62 ans mais enfin si
vous partez à 62 63 vous gagnez moins
c'est inacceptable après on a vu que de
l'espèce de grandes comédies mais ça a
été un moment donné où la cfdt mais
aussi mon organisation
ça nous a permis d'avoir un point
d'appui pour dire dont arrêté arrêté
parce que plus personne d'abord on
comprend rien à votre système
d'ailleurs la meilleure preuve c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on nous dit qu'on va
faire une conférence à juste titre sur
le fil grâce financement passait pas en
amont qu'il fallait le faire ça ne
comprend pas que quelqu'un puisse
commencer à comprendre quelque chose
dans ce qu'on veut nous faire dans le
financement comment jean claude l'a très
bien dit tout à l'heure
donc la cheville beau ça a permis de
dire bon allez là on a quelque chose
c'est un peu le rochelle qui peut
paraître s'accrocher rester ça ne
pourrait sauver le financement s'il n'y
avait pas d'autres d'autres moyens et je
note comme tout le monde ici je crois
que quand on dit il a été retiré
provisoirement temporairement six cadets
voilà en tous les cas quand on prépare
un texte
du point de vue de l'exécutif forcément
on va lâcher des choses on sait l avance
donc on
on s'y prépare ouais enfin j'ai pas le
sentiment qu'ils ont envie de lâcher
beaucoup de choses hein franchement
alors ils ont réglé après ils ont eu des
négociations séparées quand j c'est
pareil avec certaines catégories la ratp
la sncf là je vois que les avocats
seront reçus la semaine prochaine et
c'est bon ils font beaucoup plus de
concertation dans les médias c'est
catégorielles catégorie terrain mais sur
le fond sur l' architecture pour le
moment il ne cède
il ne cède rien sur l' architecture
globale du système je les vois pas je
les vois pas céder pour le moment
maintenant vous savez un projet de loi
de son quarante et une page sap a été
rédigée en quinze jours vous parce que
ça lui préparait depuis depuis un bout
de nos avec y compris lui même pas 24
heures avant l'heure oui il traduit ça
aussi c'est une méthode pour l'envoyer
au dernier moment ça c'est pas la
première fois entre 12 régulièrement
oui ça arrive ça arrive régulièrement
mais il ya ça veut dire qu'il y avait un
travail de la haute administration soit
bercy la direction de la sécurité
sociale sa joie qui vous savez moi je
poursuive ça depuis très longtemps je
perçois des mois qui a une petite
revanche de certains hauts
fonctionnaires qui ne supportaient pas
par exemple de ne pas pouvoir être
directeur de caisse de sécurité sociale
ou directeurs d'institutions de
prévoyance balle ils vont pouvoir parce
que tout va et étatisée jean paul huchon
pour vous
l'âge pivot routier s'est pas vraiment
une mesure qui a été retirée salon dont
je pense qu'elle a été
on pourrait aller à l'extrême et dire
comme certains que tout ça était prévu
pour être retirée et donner un appui à
soi disant qu'on vend me on peut le dire
comme ça mais ça donne en tout cas
positifs pour le syndicat réformiste de
laurent berger de dire voyez ce qu'il
faudrait c'est un jeu politique aussi il
faudrait un jour peut-être c'est se
pencher sur ce vol de câbles de
syndicats réformistes
moi je ne comprends pas ce que ça veut
dire que ça veut dire syndicales font
lui ça veut dire pas la cgt ça veut dire
favorable au dialogue social
il est contestataire on a fait une info
que les gens poser cette question il me
définis comme ça les cas réformiste la
norme pour la réforme s'appelle de
l'agitation ça veut rien ne lie les
bonnes réformes et les mauvaises
réformes mais le merci c'est qu'on a
dans ce pays c'est que le mot de réforme
maintenant inquiète x est un mot qui ont
dit réforme se dire oh là là on va y
perdre quelque chose c'est tout à fait
ça que les gens pensent et dire
aujourd'hui on sait toujours pas où on
en sera au niveau de notre retraite les
uns ou les autres ceux qui sont déjà en
retraite
ils savent à peu pas mais les autres non
il n'y a pas eu de préparation de tout
ça c'est quand même fou c'est que
pendant deux ans presque on a baladés
tout le monde etc mais qu'on a jamais
dit quelles étaient les conséquences ce
que disait tout à la gente rôle de
monsieur 12 qu'est ce qu'on va faire de
tous ces organismes a regroupé ccc 7/1
réforme qui n'a pas été préparée et qui
repose quand même posé par sur un
mensonge il ya deux mensonges le premier
fait que moi je ne suis pas persuadé que
ce plan financier on soit dans la
difficulté qu'on dit à ses premiers
points des économistes sérieux l'ont dit
et le redit facile points et le deuxième
point c'est que de toute manière
in fine et
on ne sait pas du tout comment tout ça
va retomber sur les gens qui
actuellement ont des certitudes sur leur
retraite aujourd'hui c'est comme la
retraite c'est un rendement très
important dans la vie c'est le moment on
peut commencer à faire des choses qu'on
n'avait pas pu faire avant et maintenant
c'est tout on va et il n'y avait pas
d'urgence
et tout ça c'est parti d'une espèce
d'intuition de départ sans doute dû
perdre l'appui goût de ses conseillers
et puis ils ont prétendu que on avait
voté macron pour ça fait pas moins face
deux mots sur ce qu'on appelle le rêver
les syndicats réformistes contestataires
moi j'ai toujours trouvé ça un peu
ridicule comme comme classification n'y
a pas de syndicat révolutionnaire en
france un plan la révolution quelques
groupuscules ici ou là peut-être cnt ou
hautement donc après il ya des syndics
quand vous allez dans les entreprises
tous les syndicats signent des accords y
compris la cgt alors au niveau national
c'est différent une notion de la cgt
s'est rarement engagés dans des accords
interprofessionnels cftc fo et cfdt
s'est très souvent s'engagent dans des
dd d'accord interprofessionnel temps
après il ya des degrés dans le
réformisme il ya déjà plus ou moins mais
a pris à des syndicats vraiment
normalisation d'origine de saint
françois hirsch est toujours adhérent et
réformistes
c était moi j'y allais plus réformatrice
c'est pas une critique c'est que les
plus sur des projets de société etc
il ya des nuances si elle est pluralisme
syndical c'est qu'il ya des nuances mais
bon mais faut pour un gouvernement
réformiste et ceux qui acceptent
voilà vous pour un gouvernement quel
qu'il soit voilà un bel et bien ils
seraient parmi les femmes aiment là où
vous rendez compte ils tort même les
bars légal puisque pour pouvoir intégrer
une organisation qui n'est pas
représentative y baissent le score de la
représentativité à puisque pour être
représentatifs nationalement pour faire
au moins 1 8% pour être à la table des
négociations
l'unsa pour pas la cité est en dessous
10% donc ils ont baissé à 5 comme ça il
va forcément choisi comme on choisit
pour les municipales ou pas mais c'est
vrai qu'on regarde ce sondage qui a été
diffusée dans les échos un sondage est
là qui dit que 42% des français pensent
que le goal les syndicats de salariés
s'opposent trop au gouvernement 59%
dépenses que les syndicats sont plus un
élément de blocage que de dialogue et
46% des sondés estiment que l'avis des
syndicats n'est pas assez prise en
compte par l'exécutive mba et s'intitule
contrebalancer mais néanmoins dans cette
affaire de l'histoire des retraites
l'exécutif en a pris un coup en terme
d'image mais les syndicats aussi
pourquoi pour quelles raisons selon vous
lydia guirous ce jeu je pense que c'est
dû à
à la mobilisation de certains syndicats
et notamment en ile-de-france avec les
blocages des transports qui ont rendu la
vie d
des personnes qui vivent en ile de
france impossible je pense que c'est à
cause de ça et puis qui la cgt c'est fin
c'est très difficile d'avoir un dialogue
quand quand leurs conditions c'est le
retrait pur et simple c'est un peu
difficile de pouvoir négocier ensuite
donc je crois que c'est c'est pour ça et
puis pour revenir sur sur la réforme
parce qu'ils me ce qui me surprend c'est
qu'on ait parlé d'universalité de fin
des régimes spéciaux et puis on se rend
compte que finalement on arrive à des
régimes par catégorie donc je suffit
spécifique donc en fait on occupe ce mal
il est resté sur la tombola
ce sont plus des régions change de mots
mais c'est à peu près la même chose et
finalement c'est ce qui bloque le plus
qui ceux qui sont plus nuisibles qui
crée plus forts qu'ils obtiennent un
maintien de leur régime spécifique ou
catégoriels ont choisi le mot qu'on veut
et là dessus je trouve que bas que le
gouvernement d'une certaine manière à a
reculé mais en camouflant ça avec un une
bonne communication
j'aurais qu'on écoute laurent escure
justement de l'unsa qui lui mettons
cause la cgt un peu trop jusqu'au
boutiste à son goût écouter cgt force
ouvrière ont quand même amené un certain
nombre de salariés dans le mur est ce
qu'on leur avait promis à cgt ou avec
mélenchon d'un embrasement social
n'arrive pas et voilà donc on leur avait
promis un embrasement social le la
guerre entre entre les syndicats
justement sur ce qu'ils veulent à tout
prix tenir dans la rue et ce qu'ils il
faut avancer
ça aussi c'est une querelle de longue
date sur laquelle joue le gouvernement
oui il faut il faut se souvenir c'est
quand même la première fois que ça se
passe dans la vie sociale fonds telles
qu'une grève aussi longue soit toujours
aussi populaire relativement populace
qui n'inquiète donc à quelque chose que
je ne crois que je crois pas que
l'opinion soit hostile aux syndicats
aujourd'hui
les gens se rendent compte aussi que
pour se défendre contre des gens qui un
blocage plus que de dialogue vous avez
dans cette année qu'un sondage
évidemment mais il y en a eu d'autres
une même filière que tu es tout à fait
différent donc il faut faire attention à
ça je ne crois pas qu'on soit dans une
situation aujourd'hui
ou y ait d'un côté une approbation du
gouvernement et de l'autre côté un rejet
des syndicats c'est pas du tout ça c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué et c'est la
raison pour laquelle ça dure et ça
continue a duré d'autant plus que le
vent ne montre pas les cartes sur un top
parce que là on fait pas du tout où ça
va aller y compris sur la suivait ou une
pinet et puis cette mesure cette manière
de mettre les syndicats devant
l'obligation fond de se mettre d'accord
entre eux alors qu'on sait que le
patronat n'est pas d'accord et le mu
rapaz son écot utilisation par exemple
un vrai moi je personnellement je pense
que la sphère des cotisations n'est pas
une mauvaise affaire
mais il faut il faut accepter d'en
discuter
la première fois nous a donné une partie
de la clé de cet évent 25 contradictions
apparentes les mêmes personnes qui
souffrent au quotidien notamment région
ile-de-france mais paca région
ile-de-france du blocage des transports
quand pas de re r combat de métro qui
peuvent pas aller au travail qui perdent
des heures etc
les mêmes disent ça on n'en veut plus
parce qu on en souffre au quotidien
mais même en même temps on leur légitime
inquiétude sur les retraites donc il n'y
a pas de contradiction peut pas opposer
aussi simplement il ya ceux qui
apportent cette forme de d'agacement
enfin voilà vis-à-vis des syndicats mais
en même temps sur les travailleurs les
plus précaires les plus vulnérables qui
subissent ces blocages pense notamment
ceux qui travaillent dans la
restauration ceux qui travaillent la
nuit ce qu'ils sont et société de ménage
qui arrivent pas aller travailler qui
ont des horaires manquantes assistantes
maternelles à la crèche me raconte
qu'elle fait six heures de trajet par
jour pour venir travailler est rentrée
chez elle le soir ils se sont dans un
état d'épuisement
alors ils sont agacés mai mais en menant
la sage
saint-gilles on rejette la faute sur le
gouvernement une pasteurisation ccsa
gecas qui protège les acquis sociaux et
qui protègent leur situation et c'est
aussi ça une utilité des syndicats le
premier ministre a dit là est la grève
n'a que trop duré en suisse qu'il a dit
cette semaine
évidemment il a raison je mourrai
d'accord personne ne payeraient pour le
plaisir et on rit on l'a vu beaucoup de
personnes aussi souhaiterait manifester
plus longtemps mais c'est aussi la
guerre du portefeuille finalement stable
7 c sur le pourrissement finalement que
joue le gouvernement ils sont joués où
ils ont joué pourrissement c'est clair
voilà il aurait pu ouvrir les
discussions bien plutôt une bouille +108
non ils n'ont pas complètement réussi
puisque je pense qu'ils ont un moment
espéré que la trêve de noël elle est
réelle et que ce serait et un bras ce
n'est pas le cas il ya même si ça fait
un peu symbolique mais moi ya des images
qui m'ont marqué quand vous voyez les
avocats qui balancent leur robe d'avocat
quand vous voyez des médecins qui
balancent leurs blouses quand vous voyez
des profs qui jette des livres quand
vous voyez les salariés du mobilier
national qui posent leurs outils etc
c'est le symbole de leur travail qu'ils
sont en train de remettre c'est quand
même sur en images c'est quand même très
fort comme com cheap mais c'est quand
même très fort comme type d'image ya un
vrai il ya un vrai malaise et gilet
jaune ce qui nous ont posé comme
problème au delà des questions fiscales
etc
franchement c'est pas réglé nonobstant
les 17 milliards qui ont été lâchés
d'une manière ou d'une autre ça n'est
pas réglé et là on sent très bien qu'on
a une société fracturée
est ce que vous sentez le malaise est
que le malaise est plus profond
aujourd'hui que lors de vos précédentes
batailles en tout cas pour la loi
travail et la réforme des retraites 2010
oui parce que il ya une volonté d'aller
vite
vous savez le temps le temps social n'a
rien à voir avec le temps politique
1 on n'est pas soumis aux mêmes on n'est
pas soumis au rythme électorale des
élections quel que soit le temps
politique fait les politiques d'une
manière générale ça ils sont aussi
rythmée par leurs propres leurs propres
élections ce qui n'est pas le cas il ya
des élections sociales dans les
entreprises etc
mais c'est tous les jours qu'il ya des
élections donc mais alors ils veulent
aller vite
moi je me souviens au début quand il
était élu prenne un public
manyula qu'on m'avait dit je vais tout
faire en deux ans pour y aura pas tout
fait en deux ans mais voilà mais on peut
pas bousculer un pays comme ça c'est
puis la réalité nous rattrape quand vous
évoquez la loi travail à juste titre
regardons bien toutes ces nouvelles lois
ou à chaque fois on a vendu les choses
mais vous savez la france va se
redresser mais ça va aller mieux mais ce
qu'on vous demande comme effort va
porter ses fruits
on se rend compte que c'est pas vraiment
ça regardez aujourd'hui comment des
mères les politiques viennent le dire
mais nos territoires se vident
d'ailleurs on vient d'avoir une étude
qui nous dit que la carte des jets et
jaune c'est la carte des territoires
caisses vides
oui les territoires résoud à cause de
quoi notamment à cause de l'ouverture
des grandes surfaces le dimanche
d'ailleurs que l'ouverture des centres
commerciaux et les grandes surfaces
c'est la mort du commerce de proximité
qui le dit depuis des mois des mois et
des années et les conséquences sont
lourdes et les français quittent à petit
se disent mais on nous dit que ça va
aller mieux mais ça va moins bien c'est
un problème pour les maisons qui
considérait ça fait parfois comme
emmanuel macron c'est pas le premier
mais quand elle était ministre de
l'économie il a peu défendu le commerce
de proximité et le repos dominical
iman le pen a réagi quand
la cfdt la cfdt pardon à s'est félicité
du retrait de l'âge pivot elle les a
traité d'idiot utile du maquereau nisme
c'est ce qu'a dit également manon aubry
cette semaine regarder la cfdt qui joue
le rôle de l'idiot utile comme ils se
sont fait avoir
d'ailleurs au moment de l'assurance
chômage où ils ont topé avec le
gouvernement et ont regretté par la
suite en se rendant compte que c'est une
saignée sociale
jean-paul ils sont ce terme est bien
choisi selon vous il est vache il est
dur mais c'est dur pour la fête d'été
parce que c'est quand même une
organisation syndicale respectable et
qui se bat pour obtenir des résultats
pour les salariés mais il faut
reconnaître que à travers ce conflit ce
n'est pas la première fois nicole notât
avait déjà eu des difficultés lors de la
première réforme fillon etc
c'est pas là parfois et c'est moi je
dirais à côté du repos mais je dirais
malgré tout la fête d'été il ya toujours
ce même problème
elle veut faire de la politique est
quelque part elle fait un peu de
l'anarcho syndicalisme et donc c'est un
peu elle va travaux sentiment aux
actionnaires c'est à sa création 64 voix
là puisqu'elle a doublé la cgt sur la
gauche mais que ça rappelle pas temps en
temps il faut le rappeler c'est
intéressant de voir l'histoire sociale
de notre pays demande comment il se
construit ben je pense que d'abord il
n'est jamais bon dans le débat comme
cela devenir les uns sont les idiots je
suis en désaccord c'est pour ça que je
suis d'accord avec tous avec force
ouvrière mais je reconnais leur travail
parce que leur travail je le vois au
quotidien
d'abord dans les entreprises où là les
lignes syndicats sont plus floues c'est
la personne humaine qui fait souvent le
travail mais il ya un véritable travail
utile nécessaire fait part lui % de
syndiqués en france au service de 100%
des salariés ça faut jamais l'oublier
et même si je suis pas un très très
grand ami de la cfdt voilà c'est comme
ça mais dans l'organisation dans le en
face est une organisation qui fait un
réel travail avec des gens qui
s'engagent et je trouve que dans une
société où on manque d'engagement il
faut soutenir ceux qui s'engagent quand
on n'est pas d'accord on leur dit et là
on a quand même un gouvernement de saad
en démocratie je ne suis en désaccord
avec ce que je connais du projet sur les
retraites mais je reconnais gouvernement
d'avoir été démocratiquement élu et
d'avoir le droit de prendre des
décisions comme j'ai le droit et le
devoir de les critiquer si je pense
qu'elles sont critiquables
c'est la voie qu'a choisie la cfdt c'est
la voie de la cftc après qu'on
réfléchisse quand on va voter à quel
bulletin de vote on met un jean claude
mailly brouillage oui non et du oui tu
moi je suis déterminé ne doit pas
employer quoi je veux dire c'est trop
bon c'est facile et c'est il ya une
spécificité de la cfdt dans ce dossier
c'est que c'est la seule confédération
syndicale depuis dix ans à réclamer un
système universel c'est ce qu'elle
réclame depuis dix ans mais un peu je
pense enfin j'en sais rien mais un peu
aux cibles comme construction
intellectuelle quoi hein mais pas non
plus dans le réel et c'est donc qu'ils
sont ils en veulent mais en même temps
c'est compliqué pour eux mais bon moi je
suis en désaccord suis en désaccord avec
la notion même n'ont pas de système
universel ça peut mais en tous les cas
avec un système unique ça oui je suis en
désaccord complet
est ce que c'est que ce bras de fer sur
la réforme des retraites a réussi à
redorer en tout cas l'image des
syndicats devait redonner un certain
souffle jean paul et centre oui je pense
quand même parce que d'abord les
manifestations les actions se sont
déroulées dans des conditions
la plupart du temps très différent de ce
qui s'était passé l'année dernière est
et on a eu
une capacité de respect des uns par les
autres aussi parce que bon martinez il a
continué à faire son travail de son côté
les personnes l'a vilipendé du côté des
autres syndicats il ya peut-être un
petit exagération de la part de l'unsa
l'a récemment mais non je pense que les
syndicats ont montré qu'ils étaient
utiles tout merde ou vers un pays sans
organisation syndicale en europe
aujourd'hui encourage ces gens qui met
au pas
jupiter lui aussi peut se casser la
gueule
oui enfin france françois en mairie le
président du syndicat des cadres cfe cgc
a dit ne pas tenir compte de cette
représentativité des syndicats revient à
créer des zones de conflit et
d'incompréhension qui déstabilise la
démocratie justement le fait de mettre
en danger les syndicats sans danger pour
la démocratie joseph thouvenel oui bien
sûr mais on le voit très bien
enfin quand on regarde un peu notre
histoire de l'europe qui est passée
vieille quand l'ami mussolini est arrivé
au pouvoir première chose qu'il a fait
il a tué les il a interdit les syndicats
notamment les syndicats chrétien pas que
chaque fois c'est pareil
salut qu'à ça fait c'est vraiment la
vérité de la vie démocratique par
rapport à la vie économique
il ya évidemment les partis politiques
mais les deux doivent marcher ensemble
et toujours dénigré les uns toujours
dénigrer les autres
alors on arrive tranquillement à
installer des gens qu'ils aient de la
défiance supplémentaires oui et on tue
la démocratie et moi je trouve que notre
démocratie ont aujourd'hui je demande
qu'on la respecte et j'entends des
déclarations notamment de politiques qui
sont très dénigrants sur notre vie
démocratique qu est encore une fois
celui qui a été élu qu'une majorité même
si on n'est pas d'accord j'ai tendance à
être d'accord avec la majorité actuelle
je reconnais qu'ils ont été
démocratiquement élu
je me reconnais le devoir de critiquer
ce que je pense être critiquable et
après aux citoyens de voter parce
qu'après tout ce qu'a fait une majorité
une autre majorité peut le défaire alors
c'est ça avoir confiance en la
démocratie en danger pour la démocratie
aux interviews et bien sûr bien sûr ils
sont indispensables au dialogue social
il ya les partis politiques comme vous
l'avait dit il ya également les
syndicats et et c'est indispensable
et on a vu lorsque les syndicats été mis
de côté et lorsque ce sont des
mouvements populaires qui ont pris le
dessus comme l'année dernière avec les
gilets jaunes
on a vu ce que ça pouvait donner en
violant son incapacité à dialoguer donc
les syndicats mme sons sont très
importants pour la vie démocratique pour
la république et c'est l'heure du coup
de galles ou du coup de coeur
jingle
[Musique]
et c'est un coup de coeur pour vous jean
paul huchon c'est la comédie de paris et
l'opéra de paris même qui se mobilise
contre la réforme des retraites avec un
certain brio
oui j'ai trop vu c'était de belles
images dans un moment où tout le monde
est négatif et que ça c'était de belles
images parce que c'était à la fois
engagée il y avait un sens politique et
sociale et en l'ensemble à marseille
c'était beau et puis il y avait du monde
pour le regarder avec beaucoup de
respect donc je trouve ça tellement rare
dans la vie qu'on a aujourd'hui
et pour vous détaguer hausse c'est un
coup de coeur pour le dernier livre de
frédéric beigbeder
cl oui oui alors d'habitude c'est plutôt
des coups de coeur ou des coups de
gueule politique cette fois ci j'ai
voulu saluer le livre de frédéric
beigbeder qui s'en prend à ses pseudo
humoriste des radios publiques qui sont
de petits tyrans qui pensent que rien
est important qu'on peut se moquer de
tous qu'on peut humilier un homme
politique sans qu'ils aient le droit de
répondre sur la liberté d'expression on
peut révéler quand vous rendez dans une
mission et qu'on se moque de vous et
qu'on n'avait pas la possibilité de
répondre j'estime qu'on doit qu'on doit
quand même pouvoir répondre à ces
humoristes qui ne supportent pas lorsque
ça y est la seconde en bourse lorsqu'il
ya de l'humour en face d'eux c'est faux
rebelle donneurs de leçons et je trouve
que frédéric beigbeder dans ce dans ce
livre dénonce avec avec brio et avec une
très belle plume et beaucoup d'humour
d'ailleurs merci beaucoup lydia guirous
ce merci jean paul huchon merci de votre
contribution à cette émission merci
beaucoup joseph thouvenel et jean claude
mailly d'avoir accepté notre invitation
sur rt france c'est la fin de deux pôles
it mag
merci pour votre fidélité rester avec
nous à suivre l'info sur rt france
[Musique]
courbevoie et bien la tête était ici le
corps était allongé comme ça et les
jambes étaient là comme ça c'est pour ça
qu'il était dans cette position je
suppose
c'est très spécifique ass est mort
solitaire on a le sentiment que